hey everyone this is kevin from
thechestwebsite.com and today we're
going to be going over the
italian bologna trap which starts out in
the italian opening which is e4
e5 knight f3 knight c6 and then bishop
to c4 one of the most common openings in
all of chess
and many times black is going to respond
with the geoco piano and that is
bishop to c5 now white has kind of two
common themes that they'll go with here
both of them center around playing pawn
to c3 at some point and then pushing
forward here on
d4 they could give up upon a material
first the evans gamut so after the
bishop takes
pawn c3 bishop comes back and they push
forward here on d4 but many players
don't want to give up that pawn in the
evans gambit so they may just play
pawn to c3 first which is what the
italian bologna trap
is going to be using so after c3 black
has a couple options on there and they
could play d6
solidifying their pawn chain opening up
for the light square bishop to get
involved into the action maybe pinning
down the knight here on
f3 at some point or they could play
knight to f6 where
white's hey the whole reason you play c3
is to push forward here on d4
even if they take here you can push
forward put a lot of pressure
on their side of the board but in this
opening we're going to be looking at if
they play pawn
to d6 we're still pushing forward here
d4
after the exchange pawn takes here on
d4 then we're going to look at what
happens if black plays bishop here to
b4 which is a pretty logical move from
black standpoint
the bishop's under attack if it comes
back here to
b6 doesn't really feel like it's doing
too much but hey b4
this is there's no pawn to stop this
check here
so it looks like whites can either have
to play knight to c3
or even bishop to c2 to stop this check
now before we get into what white's best
move actually
is i do want to take a few steps back
and make sure that you
understand some concepts you should be
thinking about in a chess openings
one is this move c3 the the main thing
that you should be thinking about is
pushing forward here on d4 and the
geocopiano but another one is the fact
that this opens up for this queen to get
involved queen to b3
uh this is going to put a lot of
pressure on this f7 square with the
queen and the bishop eyeing down there
but also queen to a4 and as soon as
black plays
pawn to d6 it in any time
this tells me that this light square
diagonal right here
is open and so i need to be thinking
about
how can i at some point attack this
diagonal here
and attack the king here on e8
so later on i know that i can bring my
queen here to a4
and then if i can somehow attack this
knight if the knight's pinned already
then the knight's going to fall here but
if the knight's not there then my queen
could have a surprise attack against
other pieces so just keep that in mind
because that is going to come into play
in the baloney trap so after the
exchange right here bishop comes down to
b4 the best move from white really is to
play king 2f1 and yes this is how we
actually lay the trap
but it is also the best move and i'll go
over in just a minute
hey if we don't play f1 what happens if
we just play knight to c3 how does that
play out as well but we're going to be
looking at
king 2 f1 and then two options we are
going to look at from black
one is if they just develop materials so
they don't have
a attack on the king right away
this pawn here on d4 is protected by our
knight
and our queen so that the knight can't
come this bishop here on b4
can't do anything else and so they may
say let's get more material involved
into the game they could play
knight to f6 or they could play bishop
down here to
g4 so let's look at both of those
options the first one here on
knight to f6 and remember what we talked
about
is that this light square diagonal here
with the king at the end here on e8 is
vulnerable
and so we can start to chip away at this
one piece here
on c6 by playing pawn to d5
and once that knight moves since it's
under attack then white can play the
move queen
to a4 this is check and you can see this
bishop here on
b4 is going to fall and that
is essentially what the bologna trap is
to get that free
piece here on b4 now even if they
don't play knight to f6 you can still
have a very strong attack let's say they
played bishop down here to
g4 in this case we could play bishop or
queen to b3 and you can see this
is not only attacking the bishop it is
defended by the knight right now but we
can
play pawn to d5 at some point if we want
to but you can see it's also
threatening this square here on f7
and so black really has to deal with
that
and even if they take our knight right
here
uh it may be tempting to play something
like bishop to
f7 and then take with your queen over
here but i think you just take with your
pawn
now many times you may look at this and
say wow you know that that doesn't
really give
my king protection on the king side but
also you got to keep in mind that you're
not going to be castling on the king's
side
and so right now your rook is really
blocked in and there's no real
good way to do that you're also eyeing
down your material on the king side of
the board
and so by playing pawn takes here on f3
this opens up for your rook to come to
the semi-open
file here on g1 and have your rook
enter the attack alongside your light
square bishop your queen
and you can easily get your dark square
bishop involved as well
now if we come back we said we're gonna
look at what happens if we don't play
that king to f1 the main difference
let's say we play that knight to
c3 and then they play knight to f6 so
same situation as before but now we play
d5 yes the knight could just come to
let's say e5 as we said before and then
we can deploy
our queen to a4 but they have an
in-between move
and that is because the king is not on
f1
they can just exchange their bishop here
on c3
so after the pawn takes now that i can
come here to
a5 and now the threat is gone
even if the queen comes to a four check
well now just pawn to c6 this
knight here on a5 is protected by the
queen
the check has stopped from the queen
here and then black's going to be
looking to play pawn to
b5 with tempo here and gain control on
the queen side of the board
while black is or while white's really
trying to figure out okay how do i
continue the
attack so that is why if we come back
here i recommend not playing
the knight to c3 but instead playing the
king
2 f1 almost hoping that there's some
exchange right here so you can get your
rook over here to g1 but if they do
fall for the ultimate trap and that is
trying to get their
pieces involved into the game like
knight to f6 which makes a lot of sense
you have recognized that this light
square diagonal here is a huge weakness
you can remove that piece on this light
square diagonal
with pawn to d5 and after that rook the
knight moves
then the queen can come here to a four
check
and capture this bishop here on b4 so
that is the
italian bologna trap since i know many
of you do like to play the italian
opening i think you may have some
opportunity
to deploy this trap on your opponents
but thank you guys so much for watching
another trap video if you wouldn't mind
hitting that like button definitely
helps the channel out
a lot lets me know that you like these
videos but thanks so much for watching
and i'll see you guys in
the next video
you